[Musique]
imaginez
vous êtes étudiant et vous avez trouvé
l'annonce de votre vie
tout vous convient
la mission
l'entreprise le salaire la localisation
dans une minute vous allez recevoir
l'appel de la DRH pour vous annoncer la
bonne nouvelle ou pas ceci étant vous
êtes confiant tout s'est très bien passé
je vous laisse je vois votre téléphone
qui s'affiche
allô oui bonjour Véronique Millet
société sacrin
pour faire suite à votre candidature
malgré votre motivation et votre CV nous
n'avons pas donné suite à votre poste au
revoir
bip bip bip
quelle émotion ressentez-vous à cet
instant
de la frustration de ne pas avoir pu
poser de questions de la colère dans la
façon d'annoncer la réponse
ou de la tristesse de ne pas avoir eu le
poste de votre vie
ça y est c'est parti pour 15 jours de
galère 15 jours à vous ressasser la même
chose
ah là là là mais si seulement si
seulement je ne pouvais ne plus avoir
d'émotions négatives
je suis sûr qu'un jour vous avez
peut-être eu cette pensée
alors debout à moi je vous rassure c'est
un doux rêve les émotions positives et
négatives font partie de notre quotidien
mais d'ailleurs
quelle définition donneriez-vous au mot
émotion
pas facile
Joseph le 12 spécialiste sur le sujet à
cette phrase que j'aime beaucoup
les émotions nous savons ce qu'ils sont
jusqu'au moment où il faut les définir
ce sujet cette phrase occupe les
philosophes et les psychologues depuis
la nuit des temps
mais aujourd'hui de vous à moi
j'aimerais qu'on trouve cette définition
et vous partagez celle qui me convient
le mieux
une émotion c'est un état affectif
intense
agréable ou désagréable caractériser par
un sang un changement physiologique ou
chimique
pour compléter cette phrase j'aimerais
vous rappeler les six émotions primaires
qui sont les émotions que nous avons dès
notre enfance dès notre naissance
la peur
la colère
notre tristesse
la surprise
le dégoût
à ces six émotions primaires vont
s'ajouter au fil des années une rime en
belle d'émotion secondaire
maintenant que nous avons défini le mot
émotion il ne serait peut-être bien
qu'on puisse s'intéresser à commenter
une émotion allez je vous emmène avec
moi au Canada on est au cœur de la forêt
au cœur en fait d'une forêt de sapin
le ciel est bleu les oiseaux chantent
tout va très bien
sauf que là devant nous un ours
forcément la peur s'installe
essayons de comprendre comment est né
cette peur
l'ours et le stimulus
l'information arrive par les yeux les
oreilles arrivent au cerveau et de là
elle prend un chemin avec deux circuits
un peu comme une autoroute vous avez la
voie rapide et vous avez la voie lente
l'information dans les deux dans le même
moment va prendre les deux chemins
l'avoir rapide va nous emmener au centre
des émotions là où se trouve l'amygdale
vous savez cette petite glande qui
depuis la nuit des temps et bien vous
permettre de vous adapter à
l'environnement et vous permet de réagir
par rapport aux dangers
et puis l'information va également aller
jusqu'au néo-cortex les néocortex lui va
prendre plus de temps c'est la partie
sur l'autoroute la voie lente il va
aller chercher dans vos expériences
passées vos souvenirs les émotions que
vous avez déjà vécu ces informations
vont revenir au thalamus et vont vous
permettre de faire des choix
sauf que si danger il y a l'amygdale va
lancer le signal d'alerte elle va
envoyer des hormones dans votre corps
pour pouvoir vous amener à vous mettre
en action et ce au niveau des muscles et
au niveau physiologique au niveau
chimique dans le sang
de façon plus concrète on appelle il y a
trois réactions à réagir par rapport à
l'ours
la fuite
la bataille
ou l'immobilisme
de façon plus concrète reprenons
l'histoire que j'ai commencé juste avant
il s'avère que la société sacrin vous a
rappelé et oui vous avez eu le poste de
votre vie
nous sommes samedi soir vous êtes assis
à la table familiale votre mère est
juste devant vous votre sort à votre
gauche est assise face à votre père
Vous annoncez à vos parents la bonne
nouvelle j'ai été embauché dans la
société ça craint
vos parents sont fiers et vos parents
vous félicitent
sans avoir le temps de leur répondre
vous observez le langage corporel de
votre sœur
non mais vous exagérez moyen non je vous
ai demandé de m'acheter un véhicule et
vous m'avez dit non et puis là vous lui
dites oui tout de suite
sincèrement on connaît qui est le
préféré dans la famille
face à cette réactions forcément vous
lui répondez non mais arrête il y a pas
de préférer dans la famille c'est juste
que je travaille bien c'est tout
le temps monte et la soirée est fichu
qu'avez-vous observé sur le langage du
corps de votre sœur vous avez vu le
corps a reculé la main à gratter un
petit peu la gorge les yeux ce sont
écarts qui est avec un mélange de peur
et de colère
et qu'est-ce que je veux montrer par
rapport à cet exemple et bien je
voudrais vous partager une première idée
qui est celle-ci
c'est que
le notre langage corporel s'exprime
par avant la prise de conscience de nos
émotions
car le l'ange médecin 18e siècle avait
déjà en fait fait ce constat avant l'IRM
qu'il y a trois grandes étapes dans la
prise de conscience d'une émotion le
stimulus la lecture du langage corporel
et seulement après la prise de
conscience d'une émotion alors qu'on
pense souvent j'ai peur et donc je
réagis mais il se passe l'inverse
car le linge avait aussi
cet élément que j'aime beaucoup qui est
de dire
est-ce que je tremble
parce que j'ai peur
où est-ce que j'ai peur
parce que je tremble
je pourrais rajouter
est-ce que je souris parce que je suis
heureux ou est-ce que je suis heureux
parce que je souris
en effet et bien notre corps ne bouge
pas par hasard c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'homéostasie l'homéostasie c'est un
petit peu comme une balance avec deux
plateaux à même niveau
il s'avère que nous sommes en train de
discuter tout se passe très bien votre
corps n'a aucune raison de bouger sauf
qu'à un moment donné je vous pose une
question qui vous perturbe
vous risquez certainement et bien de
bouger à travers votre corps c'est
exactement comme si on avait cette
balance je prends une pomme et je place
la pomme sur un des plateaux que se
passe-t-il forcément les deux plateaux
vont être déséquilibrés jusqu'à un
moment donné où on va retrouver un
certain équilibre et bien se passe la
même chose ce stimulus extérieur fait
amen votre corps à bouger et vous faire
prendre conscience de l'émotion
et oui les émotions sont universelles
elles sont fondamentales elles sont sans
frontières
elles vous aident elles sont importantes
parce qu'elles vont vous aider dans vos
choix
pour ça j'aimerais vous faire connaître
ou faire partager vous faire rencontrer
Elliott
Elliott est avocat d'affaires il est
brillantissime
des douleurs au crâne l'amène à
consulter un médecin
il s'avère qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il a une
tumeur de la taille d'une orange
positionnée près du néocortex
il est opéré l'opération se passe bien
il a gardé sa mémoire sa concentration à
un détail près
il n'arrive plus à prendre à faire des
choix il agit comme un ordinateur
il rencontre Antonio Damasio neurologue
fort connu et Antonio Damasio se rend
compte que lors de l'opération il y a
une rupture entre l'amygdale et néo
cortex
c'est ce qui l'empêche de pouvoir faire
des choix et d'agir comme un ordinateur
du coup qu'est-ce que je veux montrer
par rapport à cette histoire d'Elliott
c'est que bien évidemment
l'amygdale et le cortex travaillent en
relation il y a une vraie corrélation
mais avant tout
le deuxième point à mettre en avant et
celui-ci
les émotions positives et les émotions
négatives
vont vous permettre de prendre des choix
de prendre de bonnes décisions en toute
conscience et en toute confiance
alors au lieu de vouloir les fuir les
enfuir les rejeter les mettre de côté
et bien pour conclure j'aimerais vous
partager la lecture d'un livre livre que
j'ai lu il y a 25 ans écrit par Gérard
Apple d'orfer je mange donc je suis il
associe le grignotage
aux émotions
et il explique que vous savez le
dimanche soir ou pendant l'entracte vous
allez aller chercher un petit carré de
chocolat
ce petit carré de chocolat il explique
qu'avant de toucher ce carré de chocolat
il est primordial de pouvoir
identifier et de pouvoir nommer
l'émotion qu'on ressent
est-ce que c'est émotion est due à de la
peur du film que vous avez vu est-ce que
c'est dû à de la frustration de ne pas
avoir été pris au poste de votre vie
est-ce que c'est lié à la colère suite à
la dispute avec votre sœur donc il
invite et c'est le conseil que je
souhaiterais vous donner à suivre c'est
la prochaine fois que vous allez
peut-être prendre un carré de chocolat
ou que vous allez être dans une relation
vous allez vous sentir un petit peu
perturbé vous allez ressentir une
émotion qui vous
perturbe la vie et bien c'est avant tout
de pouvoir
identifier l'émotion
de pouvoir la nommer je suis triste je
suis heureuse je suis en colère je suis
frustrée et c'est ce qui va vous
permettre d'apprendre à apprivoiser vos
émotions et oui vos émotions dans leur
diversité sont votre plus belle richesse
sachez les cultiver les apprivoiser
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire depuis
plus de 25 ans et c'est ce que je
souhaitais vous partager aujourd'hui je
vous remercie pour votre écoute et je
vous souhaite une vie pétillante
d'émotion
[Applaudissements]